when we compare triangle abc to triangle
xyz it's pretty clear that they aren't
congruent that they have very different
lengths of their sides but there does
seem to be something interesting about
the relationship between these two
triangles one all of their corresponding
angles are the same so the angle right
here angle bac is congruent to angle y x
z
angle b c a is congruent to angle y z x
and angle a b c is congruent to angle
what x y z so all of their angles
they're the corresponding angles are the
same and we also see we also see that
the sides are just scaled up versions of
these of each other so to go from the
length of x z to ac
we can
we can multiply by three we multiplied
by three there to go from to go from x y
the length of x y to the length of a b
which is the corresponding side we are
multiplying by three
we had to multiply by three and then to
go from the length of y z to the length
of bc we also we also multiplied we also
multiplied by 3. so essentially triangle
a b c is just a scaled up version of
triangle x y z if they were the same
scale they would be the exact same
triangles but that one is just a bigger
a blown up version of the other one or
this is a miniaturized version of that
one over there if you just multiply all
the sides by three you get to this
triangle and so we can't call them
congruent but there this does seem to be
a bit of a special relationship so we
call this special relationship
similarity so we can write that triangle
triangle a
b c
is similar
similar to triangle and we want to make
sure we get the corresponding sides
right a b c is going to be similar to x
y z
to
x y z and so based on what we just saw
there's actually kind of three ideas
here and they're all equivalent ways of
thinking about similarity one way to
think about it is that one is a scaled
up version of the other so scaled
scaled up or down version of the other
down
versions when we talked about congruency
they had to be exactly the same you
could rotate it you could shift it you
could flip it but when you do all those
things it would have to essentially be
identical with similarity you can rotate
it you can shift it you can flip it and
you can also scale it up and down in
order for something to be similar so for
example if you say if something is
congruent if
if let me say triangle
let's say triangle c d e
if we know that triangle c d e is
congruent to triangle f
g h then we definitely know that they
are similar they are scaled up by a
factor of one then we know for a fact
that c d e is also similar to triangle f
g h but we can't say it the other way
around if if triangle abc is similar to
xyz we can't say that it's necessarily
congruent and we see for this particular
example they definitely are not
congruent so this is one way to think
about similarity the other way to think
about similarity is that all of the
corresponding angles will be equal
so
if something is similar then all the
corresponding angles are going to be
congruent
corresponding
angles
always have trouble spelling this it is
two r's one s
corresponding
angles corresponding angles are
congruent
are congruent so if we say that triangle
abc is triangle abc is similar to
triangle xyz that is equivalent to
saying that angle
angle abc
is congruent or we can say that their
measures are equal to angle x y z
to angle x
y z
that angle
that angle bac
be
ac is going to be congruent to angle y x
z
to angle y
x z and then finally
angle
a c b
is going to be congruent to angle
to angle x y
x z y
angle x z y so if you have to add two
triangles all of their angles are the
same then you could say that they're
similar or if you find two triangles and
you're told that they are similar
triangles and you know that all of their
corresponding angles are the same and
the last i guess way to think about it
is that the sides are all just scaled up
versions of each other so the sides
so sides
scaled by the same factor scaled by same
same factor in the example we did here
the scaling factor was three it doesn't
have to be three it just has to be the
same scaling factor for every side if
this side if we scaled this side up by
three and we only scaled this side up by
two then we would not be dealing with a
similar triangle but if we scaled all of
these sides up by seven then that's
still a similar as long as you have all
of them scaled up by or scaled down by
the exact same factor so one way to
think about it is and i want to keep
having well i want to still visualize
those triangles let me let me redraw
them right over here a little bit
simpler because i'm not talking now in
general terms not even for that specific
case so if we say that this is
a
b
and c
and this right over here is
x
y
and z i just redrew them so i can refer
to them when we write down here if we're
saying that these two things right over
here are similar that means that
corresponding sides are scaled up
versions of each other so we could say
that
the length of a b
we could say that the length of a b
a b is equal to some scaling factor and
this thing could be less than one some
scaling factor times the length of x y
the corresponding sides and i know that
a b corresponds to x y because of the
order in which i wrote this similarity
statement so some scaling factor times
x y
we know that
bc the length of bc
we know the length of bc needs to be
that same scaling factor that same
scaling factor times the length of y z
times the length of y z
so that same scaling factor and then we
know the length of ac
the length of ac is going to be equal to
that same scaling factor times x z
so that's x z and this could be a
scaling factor so if a b is larger than
if a b c is larger than x y z then these
k's will be larger than one if they're
the exact same size if they're
essentially congruent triangles then
these k's will be one and if x y z is
bigger than abc then these scaling
factors will be less than one but
another way to write these same
statements notice all i'm saying is
corresponding sides are scaled up
versions of each other this first
statement right here if you divide both
sides by x y you get a b
over x y
is equal to our scaling factor
and then the second statement right over
here if you divide both sides by yz you
get b let me do that same color
you get
b c
divided by y z is equal to that scaling
factor
is equal to that scaling factor remember
the example we just showed that scaling
factor was
scaling factor was three but now we're
saying in the more general term
similarity as long as you have the same
scaling factor
and then finally if you divide both
sides here by the length between x and
xz or segment xz's length you get ac
over x z
is equal to k as well
is equal to k as well or another way to
think about it is the ratio between
corresponding size notice this is the
ratio between a b and x y a b and x y
the ratio between b c and y z b c and y
z the ratio between a c
and xz ac and xe that the ratio between
corresponding sides all gives us the
same constant or you could rewrite this
as a b
over x y
is equal to
b c
over y z
is equal to
is equal to ac over x z which would be
equal to some scaling factor which is
equal to k so if you have similar
triangles let me draw an arrow right
over here
similar triangles means that they're
scaled up versions and you can also flip
and rotate and do all the stuff with
congruency
and you can scale them up or down which
means all of the corresponding angles
are congruent which also means that the
ratio between corresponding sides is
going to be the same constant for all
the corresponding sides or the ratio
between corresponding sides is constant